[Musique]
bref j'avoue que tu étais pas exactement
comme sur tes photos kinder un jeu mais
mais mais t'as du charme incité pas la
question en tout cas elle est sympa ce
petit restaurant je devrai goûter
l'assaut diminuait les palaces du
minurso n'a en tous cas moi ce qui m'a
fait marrer sur ton profil c'est quand
tu as écris je fais 22 ans de taule pour
avoir tué mon mari
parce qu on comprend que c'est une vanne
quand tu dis je les tue avec mes nichons
quoi
pétition
[Musique]
femme tentant de parade à nadal à 22,30
atteinte à la loi tendant à de
[Musique]
la la je suis vieillissement coville je
pète le feu après dix jours enfermés
attache lettre à l'une l'otage de
moi-même et bonne année à tous voilà
j'espère qu'elle sera meilleure que 21
ans elle sera meilleure que 21 à tous
très très bonne année
[Musique]
aujourd'hui que doc les amis j'ai un
coup de gueule bonjour telle table c'est
très simple toutes les personnes qui se
sont inventé des vides contrôleurs là
des agents de sûreté des agents de
police ils s'inventent des vies de
contrôleurs vous n'êtes pas contrôleur
et toutes les personnes à quand un autre
masque il est là où le
tennisman de la sécurité ni un policier
laisse nous tranquilles on a droit à
vivre un petit peu donc toutes les
personnes à qui
non laissez nous tranquilles ok mais je
vous souhaite quand même une bonne année
mettez pas à contrôler leur laisse nous
tranquilles
coucou bonne année à merci pour les
fleurs bruno bienvenus comme vous êtes
des petits gourmands j'ai apporté le
dessert alors non là tu m'apportes et
des yaourts oui mais non ce sont les
nouveaux panier de yoplait d'accord donc
toi tu t'es dit réveillon je vois les
choses en grand yaourt oui écoute
corinne je me suis cassé très mince
affaire un curry d'agneau à l'ancienne
oui 45 minutes de bagnols pour trouver
de ballotins de truffes 23 balles chacun
oui donc tu es yogourt limite tu peux te
les photos je pense et non pas si tu
fais aucun effort tu as trouvé ça dans
le bac date limite à lidl j'imagine oui
après je vois qu'il reste quand même un
goût framboise donc mais c'est chiant
corinne c'est relou en fait manu la
prochaine fois qu'on va chez eux tu
notes petit louis